now I'm delighted to say we're joined by
the director of The Institute for fiscal
studies Paul Johnson for his reaction to
the Chancellor's uh budget thanks very
much for being on the program we'll talk
Lots about the numbers I'm sure Ed will
have a bit to say about that as well
um but I was very struck by one of your
tweets uh today uh where you say note
what the chancellor didn't mention
nothing on public set to pay no
medication of big income tax Rises
coming in this April no more money for
public services post 2024 still some
pain on the way yeah it's I mean you've
just shown the um the pictures of uh
teachers striking and uh the biggest
challenge facing the government and the
argue with the country over the next
year is this public sector problems with
nurses teachers doctors and a whole
group of others who are been getting
really big pay cuts last year and this
year a government said they've only got
three and a half percent to give in the
coming year when inflation will average
more than that teachers experienced
teachers maybe 15 down on where they
were in 2010 but no mention of any
additional money me to help sort those
strikes out and no additional money post
2024 penciled in for public services
generally now public servers have
actually got quite a lot of money over
this Parliament it is true that
austerity is way behind us in that sense
but the next Parliament if those numbers
are kept to will look really tough we
just heard from James Carter she said
look this is about tax really it's not
that's something not for a budget is
that fair well not really because the
chancellor said he's sticking to his
fiscal targets he's only just by hare's
breadth meeting well it's not a
particularly sensible fiscal Target
actually which is to get debt falling in
a particular year in the future and he's
only doing that because he's making
things up he's kind of pretending that
fuel duties will go through the roof
next year well they're not going to he's
sort of pretending that I hope he's
pretending that this um corporate tax
relief will be temporary I mean he said
he wants it to be permanent it should be
uh permanent they think he's pretending
uh that public spending will be really
be really tight over the next few few
years so I don't think it's fair to say
that you know if you're putting
something so much stall by fiscal
responsibility you have to take
seriously uh what the chancellor says
about what he's intending on spending is
that right by the way what the minister
was saying that if if they had kept it
permanent that it would have broken
their rules the like an extra 9 billion
would probably would have done yes right
but again as you say the rules are their
own constructs and indeed and I I don't
think I mean look I mean it we I mean I
take rules of serious fiscal rules
probably more seriously than the 99.9 of
the population but I don't think we'd
have been throwing our hands up in
horror If instead of meeting them by 5
billion they were missing them by 5
billion uh because of uh a change they
were a permanent change on the
corporation tax thing and the problem
with doing that corporation tax change
as they done first this should have been
announced at the same time as the
corporation tax rate was increased
announced two years ago it's not
sensible policy making to change it two
weeks before the fiscal year begins and
second having made the change it should
be a permanent change because actually
structurally it's a sensible thing to do
if it's permanent it's not such a
sensible thing to do just temporarily
and Paul it seems like it was a very
targeted budget if you like there were
no big bangs in it no massive surprises
do you see it as a Chancellor pursuing a
study as she goes approach now for a
pre-election Splurge next year how did
you see it stacking up politically if
you like well I mean there were two big
things in it the corporate tax thing we
talked about the child care thing no
doubt you've covered that actually a
doubling in the amount of public
spending on child care and and really I
think moving to the end of a 2025-year
gradual change to the shape of the
welfare state it's quite a big thing
it's hard to see where there's space for
a Splurge next year given that uh you
know as I said you're barely meeting his
own fiscal rule as it is
um and growth while a little bit better
than expected isn't looking fantastic so
is he really going to have lots of money
to give away pre-election next year hard
to see I'm sure he'll find something I'm
sure he'll find some way of doing it but
I think I think this was quite a it was
a technical budget I think it was
genuinely making some changes which will
help the child care corporation tax I'm
not so sure about the pensions tax
changes
um but it was and actually changes
disability benefits these are technical
but important and broadly speaking I
think sensible change just to jump in
what why are you not so sure about the
pension and tax contributions well I
mean several reasons I mean one
Chancellor talked about it as being a
response to problems with doctors in the
NHS well if that was the target you
should have changed the NHS pension
scheme it didn't you don't need to
change the entire tax system to do it
secondly it will of course also allow
people to save more in their pension so
while some people may stay and work a
little bit longer because they can save
more some people might actually retire a
little bit earlier because they have
saved more because they've been able to
and actually
um the people who might really be
affected by this he's kept a very sharp
taper in which means if you're on above
about 200 000 pounds a year then you
lose everything that he gave very very
quickly so it's it's going to benefit a
very particular group of people on on
high earnings but not the super high
earners and could even have the opposite
effects for some others well it could
have the opposite effect for exactly
that reason so so growth was one of the
big things and kind of underlying a lot
of the Improvement in the numbers the
the fiscal numbers the economy looks a
bit better than it did last time around
and so that that matters but there was a
dispatch maybe we can show that show the
chart there is kind of a disparity
between what the obr thinks it's going
to happen to growth and what uh the bank
of England for instance thinks
um let's see if we can bring this chart
up here because it kind of shows it
um and it includes base looking uh at
what the growth profile was before
um the pandemic so it was kind of a line
basically going up you can see that
there and then where it was afterwards
but the interesting thing is so that's
the latest numbers and they're obviously
kind of they're better than they looked
last time around better than November
but then you bring the bank of England
numbers on and they're pretty they're
pretty depressing by comparison so are
we at one of these moments Paul where
actually a lot just depends on whether
the obr's got its sums right and it
could well be that everything looks you
know a bit a fair amount more Grim I
mean which of these numbers I know
you're a kind of a fiscal forecast but
which of these numbers are you more kind
of convinced by when you look at them
now well the obr is closer to what most
other forecasters are saying the bank of
England is really quite pessimistic I
mean the chancellor must be thanking his
lucky stars he's got the obr giving him
his forecast
when the bank is is really pessimistic
about the capacity of the economy to
grow
um over this period
um and the obr is is more reasonable
actually what they're talking about is
an average of two percent growth over
the subsequent few years which isn't too
bad at all I mean all I say is I just
hope the obr are right because if the
bank's wrong right then we really are in
trouble but it's it's a very strange
thing isn't it we've got monetary policy
being based on one set of forecasts and
fiscal policy being based on the
entirely different set of forecasts but
it's just a bit better I mean let's say
no no recession that's that's something
that you know that's one of the big
stories out of today I know it's an
arbitrary thing but nonetheless it
suggests the economy is better than it
was but just still pretty grim and the
next few months aren't necessarily going
to be especially the feel good Factor
isn't necessarily going to be that who
know for households to feel good factors
not here at all and I mean what they
what we what they worry about is what
their incomes what household incomes are
doing and as the you know the obr says
we might not be going into a recession
but incomes are still sharply down last
year and this year so not down by the
full seven percent they thought in
November but still down by five percent
or so still the sharpest fall in
household incomes in in certainly in
living memory and that's partly because
of course of uh inflation and earnings
not going up with prices but it's also
significantly because there's this great
big tax rise coming in uh next month
which is the you know the fact that
income tax allowances and thresholds are
not going up in line with inflation
that'll leave the average basic rate
taxpayer about 500 pounds worse off the
average higher rate taxpayer about a
thousand pounds worse off that's
actually a quite a big contributory
factor to this living standard squeeze
so it's actually it is it's partly
created by the government despite what
the minister was saying a moment ago
yeah it's interesting as well isn't it I
always like to ask this question because
it's something the government will start
you an interview it's always wonder what
the sort of actual the advice that
someone like you would be
Jeremy Hunt says this is all about
proving the doubt is wrong it's all
about you know showing that the
government policy is starting to bear
fruit when it comes to the economy how
much of this gradual Improvement is due
to the government or how much of it is
due to external factors that they have
nothing to do with well
um it depends on what your Baseline is I
mean clearly um things are doing better
than the team had the sort of mini
budget measures not been Unwound over
this year
um though this is really all about the
energy prices coming down and the
economy doing a little bit better for
other reasons though if you do look at
the um the obr numbers they do think
that a little bit of the growth at the
end and you never get more than a little
bit from what you're doing one budget is
down to this budget getting more uh
people into work in particular so I
don't think we should sort of sniff at
the fact that there's been there's quite
a lot of I think quite sensible policies
in here which over the long run will
bear some fruit
um is scoring some of that as improving
the size of the economy into the medium
term and it's really worth stressing
that getting these things right getting
corporation tax right getting child care
right getting the disability benefit
system right getting a pension taxes
right each one of them adds up into a
system which if it's just a little bit
more right does allow the economy to
grow a bit more in the future but the
issue is Paul isn't it that this is a
prime minister who has 18 months
effectively before he calls a general
election and if he can't get the economy
right and get people feeling like their
lives are getting better under this
particular Administration he's at risk
clearly of losing an election do you
think he can somehow turn it around or
are really the the sort of quite anemic
growth figures the constraints on public
finances just too big a tide for him to
turn I think a lot of it will depend on
how it feels in a year to 18 months time
as I said I think this year through to
the early summer is going to look quite
difficult
um I think the economy will begin to
grow according to these forecasts at the
end middle of this year end of the year
real incomes should start to be moving
in the right direction in a year's time
um and you know there will be an
opportunity to you know Chuck a little
bit more money at some people in the
Autumn statement in their budget next
year so it depends to some extent
whether people think well we're now on
the right path we're at least moving in
the right direction even if from a sort
of rather low point or whether they're
thinking well or still actually worse
off than we were three or four years ago
so we don't feel very good about that I
mean the truth is that you come next
summer summer 2024 house on England
probably will still be below where they
were pre um pre-pandemic and people
aren't going to be feeling very happy
about that but they may just about be
moving in the right direction by then